this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life
and your money my name is anthony
o'neill host of the
popular youtube and podcast show the
table with anthony o'neil and co-hosting
with me today is number one national
best-selling author
of business boutique has some amazing
things going on host of the
christy wright show um and killing the
game especially around ladies
and uh starting a business like
christy what's up hey this is gonna be
fun you and i get feisty i'm pretty
excited about this oh this is gonna be
so good so
this is like we haven't done this this
year have we no no
you all get ready fast in your seatbelts
two people who who love each other who
also love to talk
so uh we have two speeds a sleeve or a
hundred miles an hour there's no in
between there
is no in between with us you know we're
going to talk real fast we're going to
get straight to the question
uh and we're going to be very honest you
know and so if you have a question about
your life
about your money if you want to start a
business
um there's this is a one woman
appreciation month or woman
acknowledgement month or something like
that
um and so we have a woman uh who really
loves
helping ladies accomplish their goals
their dreams starting businesses
and so i want you to give us a call
christy wright is the i say she's the
queen really she's the king but she's a
woman so she's the queen in this space
and so give us a call at 825-5225
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five
uh you can find us both on social media
if you want to send us a question at
anthony o'neil for myself and at
christie is it right yes i thought so
christy b
wright sent us your questions and we
would love to have a conversation with
you
uh let's get straight to the phone let's
do it i love it so let's go out to
my home state north carolina raleigh
north carolina
uh good afternoon rory how can christina
help me
hey guys how are you guys doing doing
all right
hey so i had a quick question uh i'm
currently 18 years old i just moved out
of my parents house on monday
okay uh um i'm in school part-time at a
community college
and i i was just offered an internship
with amazon
it's going to be 15 15 months it'll be
paid
and i'm cash flowing college i'm paying
for everything
and i was just wondering where i should
get started with the baby steps
oh man rory this is good now uh what
community college are you going to there
in raleigh
uh it's wake tech lake technical
community college absolutely yeah i know
i know all about wake tech man i was
going to go to a fayetteville tech
uh in fayetteville north carolina about
an hour and a half away from there so i
know exactly where you're going how much
is amazon paying you man for these
uh next 18 months uh it's gonna be
twenty dollars an hour uh 40 hours a
week
what's the point of some money brother
that's what i'm talking about
okay any any debt do you have right now
do you have any credit cards
uh no sir i'm completely debt free it's
it's a uh it's a robotic
internship they just built a warehouse
here and i'm studying mechatronics so
cool yeah that's awesome
i love it i love it well you know
chrissy i think the very first thing
rory should do is really just skip over
baby step two
um and really just start saving your
three to six months rory you're a young
man you just moved out on your own
and so what i want you to do is i want
you to sit down and get on an every
dollar budget okay rory
what you're going to do is you're going
to list all of your income which is
going to be your amazon check
um if you're driving for uber eats if
you're doing anything extra i want you
to list all your income
then i want you to list all your
expenses so this is going to be you know
your rent
this is going to be you know if you have
an iphone or android phone
any apps you're paying for um you're a
young man so i'm pretty sure you're
single so if you out dating you need to
have a line item for dating okay
um so you got to get creative list all
your expenses i don't know why your
young people out here laughing at me i
know that's real
i see y'all laughing at me uh but you
know you got to put everything on there
so you can have control over your money
that's the key thing that i really want
you to understand rory you're gonna
start with baby step number three
and baby set number three is gonna be
three to six months of your living
expenses
okay and you're gonna do that by getting
on an every dollar
budget and that's the first place where
i would say start
but the key thing is man once you get
that three to six months rory if you can
do that by the end of this year and
start investing next year you'll be 19.
if you can start investing 15 percent of
your income rory but before you turn 50
you're going to be a multi-millionaire
just by doing the bare basics so i mean
i i love it i mean here's the cool thing
rory the fact that you're asking this
question
at 18 you gonna be okay like
most 18 year olds are not asking this
question not calling the ramsey show
and not cash flowing their college you
are doing
awesome you're asking the right
questions you're already set up for
success the one
caution i would give you if you take
this internship which sounds like an
awesome opportunity
you're about to have some money yes and
when you got some money you know what it
does
it wants to burn a hole in your pocket
because you're like oh i'm living good i
got all this money it feels like so much
and just like anthony's telling you
don't lose focus of your goals and your
plan just because you got a little cash
in your pocket it'll be very tempting
to overspend that so just be aware of
that stick to your plan and you're going
to be just fine that's awesome
man listen hearing those calls what so
cool yeah i was not asking that question
at 18. 18.
i was like do i get another t-shirt for
that credit card where do i sign
sign me right on up yeah i had to pay
for my mistakes in my 20s
i'm thinking about t-shirts free pizza
the ladies it's free money y'all no it's
not
no it's not no it's really not man so
rory
man take my hats off to you thank you so
much for calling in you are a true
example of what
most 18 year olds what most young people
need to be doing is thinking about their
future
and so thank you for asking that
question and make sure to check out with
me um
over on my show man i'm really gearing
my show towards that younger audience so
come over there to the table with your
boy anthony o'neil youtube podcast
and i'm gonna show you how to keep the
bag um and really build some more wealth
man i love it let's keep the
conversation going
uh triple eight eight two five five two
two five ramsey personalities anthony
o'neil and christy wright are in the
building today
um we're looking forward to having a
good show with you uh we're gonna go out
to richmond virginia and have a
conversation with matthew
uh good afternoon matthew uh real
quickly what's your question
hi there uh thanks for taking my call
yeah um
so so the question is my wife and i have
saved up a
bit of money money over the last few
years we now have enough for
our first house the problem is we don't
know if we should actually
buy our first house buy an investment
property
or hold off until we figure out where we
go next
with uh with our family okay just moved
out of new york city
the plan is to go to um the west coast
closer to family but
you know all the markets and everything
going on but just
we don't know what the next move is and
yeah maybe you can help us out a little
bit
yeah so are you do you plan on moving
within the next three years
uh within the next three months oh yeah
so then we're not buying nothing
yeah yeah so here's the thing um i don't
want you to buy anything
until you know you're going to be in
this city
for at least three to five years bare
minimum is three the ideal situation is
five
um but if you're moving within the next
three months no don't
don't buy anything because you don't
want to be a
long-distance landlord because you won't
be able to watch it
and really take care of it and then for
me personally
i'm going to buy a house actually and
live in a house before i go out and get
some rental property so put your family
into a good home
then start talking about how to generate
some more income that's good i like it
that's good it's good one yo it's
chrissy right anthony o'neill right here
on the ramsay show and we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find
healthcare coverage that would meet our
needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at ch chministries.org we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
christy wright
author of business boutique co-hosting
with fellow ramsey personality anthony
o'neil and anthony i'm so excited
because
we get to have a conversation with
someone that i absolutely
love jamie kern lima is the founder of
it cosmetics
who recently sold to l'oreal for a
billion dollars
so just a small accomplishment in her
life and she has a new book called
believe it
how to go from underestimated to
unstoppable
jamie how are you christy i'm so good
thank you so much for having me here
how fun is this that i get to talk to
you on the ramsay show with anthony we
were just talking about you off air and
how amazing
you are jamie i know so much of your
story i had the honor of having you
speak at business boutique last year
i've had you on the christy wright show
but for anyone listening that isn't
familiar with you would you just tell us
a little bit about your story
and your new book believe it yeah
you know i'm probably most well known
for going from
denny's waitress to uh creating a dream
in my living room and going after it
and and building that to it cosmetics
which is now one of the largest uh
luxury makeup companies in the country
and then selling it to l'oreal but uh
the reason i wrote believe it christy
is um you know every single day i hear
from so many people
saying oh congrats on you know your
fairy tale but i'm struggling or i'm
getting rejected or my dream's not
getting off the ground and
i realize if we don't ever share like
the real stories behind the stories
um then everyone feels alone in their
own setbacks and gets tempted to give up
and
everything else so believe it it's
really a book about
overcoming self-doubt um what to do when
when you're not getting the kind of
traction or or
or success that you're hoping for when
people like look you in the eye and tell
you you're not enough
what do you do in those situations um my
real story is you know three years of
having everyone say no
uh with it cosmetics and uh eventually
turning those nose into yeses but it was
a really long road
um really filled with a lot of
self-doubt and it's really it's really
how do you go from not believing in
yourself to believing in yourself and
i think it's not just my story it's a
story of so many people out there right
now
especially coming out of a hard season
right up 14 months and
a lot of people have been dimming their
own light and this is a book that
hopefully will help everyone
ignite their light again and learn to
believe in themselves and the
possibility of their own dream
i love that i love your story because
one of the things that's really cool
about this book anthony is she has so
many stories that you would never know
if she didn't tell it and jamie you
shared some of these stories on stage
at business boutique but i think that
people would easily look at someone like
you
and think well she just she's an
overnight success
she just magically appeared on the
mountaintop she's so lucky
all these extra things and you tell
story after story after story in this
book
of how you were looked in the face and
told no how you had to overcome
adversity overcome setbacks from
stories at qvc to trade shows where
you're literally
stalking people down the aisles trying
to get to the right person
to tell your story but you have this
even through all these stories and
setbacks
you have a tenacity you have a won't
take no for an answer
attitude and i think that that is
something so special about you would you
tell us like
where does that come from and how can
people that don't have that naturally
how can they do that
too that that may not come as as
naturally to to be such a go-getter like
that
yeah i think you know everyone listening
to the three of us right now i feel like
all of us
know inside of god's like place a dream
on our heart or
maybe there's something in us that you
know we we have that inkling where we
know we need to create or
or or or launch the business or maybe
we're in the wrong job or the wrong
relationship we all kind of
have those feelings and you know i did a
lot of things wrong that i talked about
in the book but
but the biggest theme through the whole
book really and the things that i did
right was when i had that
feeling that knowing that internal
knowing
um i made a decision to trust it and and
i think that
uh i think that so many people know if
they're kind of made for more
or they're you know have more to give or
create or they need to start painting
again or
whatever it might be but they still
doubt themselves
anyways and this book is really about
how do you
break through that that barrier of
self-doubt and step into
really the person you're born to be you
know and and yeah i was super
super hard working and super ambitious
but i think
really this is what i believe i believe
and that's why i love that you guys
share so many people's stories and so
many people that had success stories
through everything that you've done it
uh with with the ramsey companies
because when we see
other people's stories and we learn how
they got through it
that's when we like pull those stories
in we can lean on them ourselves
um so yeah my book is really about of
course working hard and
not giving up and those kind of things
but really it's about
how do you learn how to believe in
yourself and
trust yourself like hear your own
knowing and make the decisions
to trust it because i think that's
that's the ultimate success
um for all of us in our lives so james
let me ask you this question this is
anthony man good to meet you
i i've i've seen you on uh christy stage
and i'm like man she's amazing
and i have a question we have a lot of
people who sometimes
uh do not believe in themselves they
they doubt their own selves
they're scared to experience some type
of failure to go to the next next level
uh what was one thing that you had to
get over and what what could you say to
inspire
someone uh to say you know what hey
start believing in yourselves
start pushing yourself forward what
would you say to that individual
listening right now
yeah the first thing i'll say is like
i've now anthony had the blessing of
meeting
so many inspiring people that i never
could have imagined meeting
the first thing i've learned is they all
still struggle with self-doubt
so the first thing i'd say is you're not
alone anyone listening right now feels
like
oh i just don't believe in myself you're
not alone and i think that's really
important to know
but also one tool i would say is really
starting to take inventory
of who you let speak into your life
about your own dreams
a lot of us i talk in my book believe it
about how to do this in terms of like if
you imagine you have your own microphone
we all have our own microphone and
sometimes we hand our microphone over
to somebody who after we share our hopes
or our dreams or our situation with
we end up like you know self-doubt gets
bigger
right and sometimes it's our partner
sometimes it's our family
our friends people who love us but when
we share
our dreams or our hopes with them they
kind of see them through
the lens of their own fear or their own
self-doubt
and so one thing i talk about in this
journey of building belief is
learning how to like take your
microphone back from some people in your
life you can love them
but talk to them about you know what's
going on with the weather and how it's
for dinner
but you know really curating the people
around you and people listening to
your radio show right now that's a way
for people to speak
into people about things that they want
to do whether it's get out of debt or
go after their dream right curating who
you hand your microphone to who you take
it back from
super important a lot of times we you
know let everyone else's opinion get
so loud that we that we and our own self
doubt build that we don't even
hear our own truth anymore so
that's one of many things to do on the
journey
that i had to learn how to do because
anthony i was told no
so many times i was told no one will buy
makeup from someone who looks like you
with your body and your weight is what
one investor said when they passed on
investing
i was told you know i mean on and on and
on and i had to learn to turn down the
volume
on that before it took root in me and
like turn
up the volume on my own knowing and and
and people that spoke positivity in my
life wow i love that because it's so
practical
and and something anybody can do now
jamie before we go i want to ask you one
more question
because we talked about this on stage at
business boutique you've shared this
story on
the christy wright show and i know
anthony's going to love it so you are
the epitome of success
and you have a story about how you were
on the forbes richest wealth
you know self-made women list and you
didn't want to be on it
and after three years of them putting
you on it anyway you learned something
would you just real quick before we go
tell us something you learned about that
experience because i think it is such a
great lesson for men and women
as we um want to chase our version of
success
yeah you know i did not when i got that
first phone call
because listen i i've been a denny's
waitress i have
been so scrappy and worked so hard my
whole life and when we eventually sold
our company to l'oreal
they announced the purchase price it was
all over the wall street journal
everywhere
so all of a sudden i find myself on the
on the forbes list and
and the name of the list was forbes
richest self-made women and i
was mortified i was embarrassed by it i
didn't want
it to be shared and this was this went
on for three years until i had this huge
epiphany where i was like wait a minute
oh my gosh jamie i am so grateful for
your story thank you for sharing with us
thank you for being a light i love how
you are just inspiring people
to believe in themselves this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five
five two two five this is the ramsay
show and ramsey personalities chrissy
wright and myself anthony o'neil
are with you on during this hour and on
the last segment man we had the
opportunity chrissy to interview one of
your friends
uh jamie who who's clearly a success
story oh my gosh
i'm like well i kind of want to get her
on my show i'm i
she's amazing and what's so cool about
her story from starting this makeup
company in her living room to now having
a
billion dollar company that sold to
l'oreal she just has this humble spirit
and she really wants people to believe
in themselves one of the things she
didn't mention when we talked to she's
donating all the proceeds from the book
she donated her time to be at business
boutique like she's just such a generous
giving person i could have talked to her
all day um but but i wanted you guys to
know you can get her book
believe it jamiekernlima.com or
believe it dot com and i know she has an
action plan and that kind of thing i did
want to tell you anthony one story
that we didn't get to wrap up because
you'll find this fascinating so when
jamie was
uh called to be interviewed to be on the
forbes richest women
list she didn't want to be on it they
were like we're going to we're going to
publish how much you make and we're
going to publish and she's like no no no
no no like i don't want to be on it
this makes me feel uncomfortable they
said well we the the records are public
we're going to put you on it like it or
not
and they did so they published about her
year number two
same thing publisher she's like oh i
feel so weird people know how much my
business is worth how much
you know i'm wearing all this stuff year
two they put her on there without her
having a quote year three i think it was
you're three or four they call her again
to get a quote
and so by year three or four she's like
all right i think i'll i think i'll give
a quote like i think i'll actually like
maybe this could be a light for people
to help them see if i can do it
uh you know they can do it too and so
she decided to well she's talking to the
interviewer the journalist and
and she said i'm sorry it just makes me
really uncomfortable and the journalist
said
all the women do it and she said what
she said all the women don't want to be
on the list
she said what's funny is all the women
don't want to be on the list and they
feel very uncomfortable with how much
they make and that anybody's going to
know it but every single man
argues that they should be higher on the
list
about why they should be jockeying for a
higher position i was like man
women can learn something from this you
don't need to be ashamed of your success
your success
can be a light for other people to go
behind you so that's the story i was
trying to get to and we ran out of time
but she's amazing
you can get the book believe it and the
action plan at believeit.com it's just
incredible
uh how inspirational her story is what a
light she is
and i like how you just came for the
brothers on that one
ladies want to be humble guys we want to
be boastful guys sit down
no women need to stand up we got we both
got something to learn we both got
something to learn from that don't be
ashamed of what god's doing in your life
absolutely you don't need to apologize
for that so i thought that was cool
and that's a good one and for the guys
and whatever god is doing for your life
don't exaggerate it
you know yeah well you know one of the
things i see women and this is true with
business boutique but anything we have
all this is this is our posture
anthony's like
oh this little thing oh just this little
i just got this little side business oh
it's nothing
and i'm like you're diminishing not only
your own sense of self-confidence but
you're downplaying
playing the kindness and truth in
someone's compliments you're you're
apologizing for god's gifts in your life
like
this is not humility this is just not
true and so i think there's
the confidence and humility are not
mutually exclusive you can be
confidently humble and you know humbly
confident and
and you can hold your life with open
hands so anyway i just love her example
because she is gracious and humble
and insanely successful and yes you can
be both and honestly uh
all jokes aside we need to hear messages
like hers that's right
you know to go from there to now a
billionaire a wealthy woman
um i mean we need that yeah and keep
your character intact along the way it's
she's so impressive absolutely
absolutely well let's get back to the
phone
uh christy triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're having a
conversation about your life your money
you wanna start a business the lady is
in the building if you are a woman and
you need encouragement in whatever area
of your life spiritually
mentally emotionally hey christy wright
is in the building
and for all y'all young people you want
to get this bag or you want to make some
money
for the older people generation or give
us a call triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
let's go out to new york and have a
conversation with matt matt good
afternoon how can
chrissy and i help uh good afternoon a
pleasure to talk to you guys
uh so i'm about to graduate from college
uh
i have a job with secured with a seventy
thousand dollar salary okay
and i'm gonna graduate with uh thirty
thousand dollars with that okay
so i already have eight thousand dollars
saved up and i wanna like attack this
debt but uh the issue is
my my car that i currently use that i'm
going to have to use for my job
uh it's uh kind of 20 years old and uh
i suspect it's about to die in the next
year or so
so how do i like balance between like
making sure i have enough cash on hand
to like get a new car or a new used car
and uh attacking out of debt all right
so you have eight thousand dollars in a
savings right
right okay cool and you're saying you
think
the car is going to die in a year right
yeah there's nothing like like
specifically wrong with it but there's
things that have been going wrong with
it uh
recently and uh yeah yeah i'm just
concerned about it's a longevity
yeah i'll get you you ain't concerned
about the car because i think i think
you're concerned because you got the
money you want to go buy a newer car
um if nothing is going wrong with the
car right now this is what i want you to
do
i want you to take 7 000 of that and i
want you to put it towards your 30
000 of debt right now your student loans
then
what i want you to do if you start
seeing issues with your car
okay and it starts starts to have some
issues i mean some serious issues too
matt
i'm not talking about you know you think
you heard something so now you need a
car now like no it's not working it's
broke it's not drivable
then i have no problem with you pausing
paying off this thirty thousand dollars
but how old are you right now matt uh
i'm 21.
yeah yeah yeah matt so i want you to
knock out this debt
this year okay if you can be really get
gazelle focused get intense get a
purpose get
driven um you can pay off the debt this
year you're making 70 000 on there how
do you do something on the side to
generate another 20 000
this year so if you can pay off your
debt this year
then next year you can focus on saving
up cash to go buy you
a real nice quality used car so what i'm
going to say for you right now
is don't worry about purchasing a new
car right now because you said nothing's
wrong with the car
right now great i would take it to the
shop maybe get it tuned up a little bit
you can take some of your eight thousand
dollars to do that
and get a good fresh get a good oil
change maybe get some good new tires on
there
um then from there put the rest onto
your debt and just
just attack the debt then next year
let's go ahead and start the process of
saving
yeah my my advice is so similar to a
call we had a little bit earlier anthony
that i would say
you're about to get this job where
you're making 75 000 a year
you need to pretend like you're not yes
you need to pretend like you're making
25 000 a year and because if not it's
gonna be oh my gosh this new
big exciting amount of money oh i can
live a little more comfortably
i can slow down on my debt snowball or
my student loans or
like anthony said need this car and
there is some you do need a car
at some point and so that's why you need
to stay serious live on way
less than you make have that margin to
take all that extra towards your student
loan towards the car whenever you need
it
and then after that you can get a little
bit more comfortable after you get your
savings up and all that kind of stuff
but i just don't want you to take your
foot off the gas because you've got
a lot more money than you're used to
having which will be easy to do so keep
that intensity even though you're making
more money now
absolutely matt and man and listen man
you're doing things right
yeah you're 21 years old making about 70
75 000
you know the average income in america
right now is right around 48 to 54
000 depending on what part you're in so
you're ahead of the average person
in america so now let's go ahead and get
strategic let's go ahead and think about
what can we do to really set yourself up
to be successful down the road and that
is pay off all your debt
get a fully funded emergency fund and so
you do live in new york so i know the
prices up there are a little bit more
expensive so you're going to be a little
creative
but here's the main thing chris this is
what i tell everyone especially young
people
um you know when they're so young and
when they are ahead of the game a little
bit
get a clear why get a clear vision
and if you get a clear why a clearer
vision then it's going to be very easy
for you to do the things that you have
to do to be successful
but if you don't have a clear why clear
vision then you'll have
those kind of questions well should i do
this should i do that but when you have
a clear why
it there's a clear answer that you need
to take to get to your why not that but
that clear why is going to help you
avoid
the short-term temporary distractions
of the bag or whatever apparently i'm
the old people because you're like a bag
or more money i was like what does a bag
mean i guess i'm in the old
look all the young people are laughing
i'm like
i'm learning things from ao today
learning things
anyway that y will help you resist those
distractions and stay focused
i forgot i am on the ramsay show i'm not
at the table with anthony o'neil i need
to
lord jesus i'm sorry y'all the bag means
money
[Laughter]
i'm sorry james i'm sorry kelly i'm
sorry this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
have you ever wondered if an online will
is right for you do you need a trust
or a mirror wheel what kind of power
attorneys do you actually need
you hear me say everyone needs a will
and i
seriously mean this my cousin just
passed away a couple of weeks ago and
she had a very detailed will
and life insurance in place and it was
so peaceful for the family but i get a
lot of questions asking
if a simple online will is right for
someone specific situation
so with your question in mind our team
decided to build a quiz that's right
a quiz and this quiz gives you custom
results based on if
you're you are married or single where
you live
and even the size of your estate it
helps you
understand exactly what you need for
your specific situation
so i want you to take the quiz to find
out what you need to protect
your family and your wishes and you know
what your loved ones
text the word quiz two three
three seven eight nine will also text
you back a promo code for twenty percent
off your wheel so again text the word
quiz
q u i z two three three
seven and i promise you
you will think uh me christy dave
our team later because i'm telling you
chris when we lost my cousin about
actually about three weeks ago um it was
it was hard uh for our family during
that time and it still is hard for us
but to to see that she had her will in
place
and to see that she had her life
insurance in place and to see that she
had the correct powers of attorney in
place as well which
couldn't use the power's attorney then
but she had the right people on the
account to get to it
we were able to mourn with peace not
more with stress
yeah i think probably the number one
reason i would guess that people
don't do it is because they just don't
want to face it they don't want to think
about it they never get around to it
it's not fun i understand that
but gosh the peace of mind once you do
it and and we've made it so easy on
people to be able to do this
the peace of mind you have knowing that
that's all okay like i i had surgery in
november and of course leading up to
surgery
um i just want to make sure everything's
in place just in case anything wrong
you know and it's like dave we've got
everything in place and so it's just
it's just gives you the peace of mind
and also gives your family the peace of
mind so it's just uh great advice
oh man all right text word quiz quiz
23789
and your family will be very grateful
because when you have that stuff in mind
what you're telling your family is i
love you
you know that's what you're saying i
love you and thank you and i'll see you
soon
uh let's go out to indianapolis and talk
to luke
luke good afternoon uh how can christy
and i help
hey good afternoon to both of you as
always thank you for
the help you provide yeah yeah what's
going on so
yeah so at my church i i lead a group
and we're actually going through
fbu and uh this past weekend we're
talking about baby step three
three to six weeks and actually tomorrow
three six months and tomorrow
uh we will be debt free tomorrow we're
paying off event congratulations
you're excited right oh yeah because
that's tomorrow it's not today okay now
my big question my wife and i uh other
people in the group have the same
question
three versus six months so we played the
clip in the video you know based on
a single family a single income family
or how reliable
so if i can give you my circumstances i
i'd really appreciate you helping me out
three versus six months
yeah yeah yeah um so i'm retired
military 20 years so i have
retirement day that's never going to go
away i have disability from the military
that's not going to go away okay and i'm
a school teacher okay
school teacher pay of course can go away
my wife she uh we homeschool we have
seven daughters
yeah and i'm watching to play out the
window right now it's amazing a lot of
estrogen
yeah and and so um
while we are a single family income i am
the sole person
at the same time the military and the
disability comes out to about
46 000 a year and my pay
for being a teacher is about 45 000. so
it's kind of funny i get paid more for
doing nothing now than i get paid for
teaching
but uh you know but we have seven kids
so
even though some of the income is
reliable you know more kids you you have
more
events could happen that you need to dig
in more expensive that emergency
but the sooner that we can get past baby
step three i mean baby says four five
and six i've got a lot of college to
start saving up for for these kids
yeah yeah so i i don't want to put a lot
of cash in savings or
money market that's i don't need to yeah
yeah so i'm looking for advice yeah yeah
so luke what's your uh guaranteed annual
income right now
uh if i were to quit or get fired from
teaching my guaranteed income from the
military and
disability is 45 46 000. but there's not
there's no indication that
anything's wrong with the teaching right
like that's been stable up to this point
that's a hypothetical i just want to
clarify this
not only to the hypothetical i finished
my grad degree in educational leadership
i
i'm i'm thinking about being a principal
that which would of course come with the
pay raise
yeah so that's that's as far as we know
that's a steady stable job
yes yeah okay so if you're going to
combine everything then um
we're looking at 92 or 93 000. yeah 92
000 yeah so you're good with no debt um
you're perfectly fine with just three
months man
yeah i would i would just jump into and
the reason we give people a range even
when you're talking about finances that
is mathematical and formula based and
there are
steps and principles there's always
going to be a range and comfort level
there are going to be some people that
they will not sleep at night unless they
have six months
just because that's their comfort level
even if all the numbers add up fine and
there's other people that are like
i feel pretty good with three months i
want to go ahead and get that money
going into college fund so
the range is really for you to customize
that aspect of it to
your comfort level and so if you and
your wife and have a conversation you
feel good about your steady income and
you feel good at three months and
or three months worth of expenses and
you want to start to put that money
towards colleges because it's a very
valid
reason to want to go ahead and do that i
think that's totally fine i think
there's just a little bit of room for
customization within that range
absolutely i mean i totally agree with
christy we want you to choose
um now if you would have called in and
say hey i'm on a commission-based job i
don't have any savings i still have debt
which way you don't have debit until you
pay off all your debt but if you didn't
have something stable and situated
then yeah we may say hey you know go
ahead and get six months because
you're not as stable with your income
but with you you're stable
luke you have good some good income
you're out of debt
yes set aside three months and going
ahead and jump over to baby steps four
uh through six right now so i would
definitely do that
but thank you so much for for uh doing
the class and
and i before you go like i'm curious uh
throughout your debt-free journey what
was the hardest part of your journey
so i was actually going to say that for
everyone that's listening and hasn't
taken the plunge
um starting that one thousand dollars
there is a mental
leap that you have to take it's just a
mental game and if you're not willing to
take that you're not all in
and you just go ish well just don't do
it yet wait till next year when you're
ready
so making that first leap and saying
we're in it to win it
um and not going ish the first the first
step
the first step that's right yeah that's
good good advice good advice for money
or anything
just commit you know what uh uh i think
it's seth godin has a great quote he
says if you wait until you have success
to commit you'll have neither you need
to commit to this thing
whether it's the baby steps or your
business or
whatever you need to commit and then
you'll have success you will not have
success if you halfway tiptoe ish your
way through you'll never have either so
let's stay right there chrissy
let's let's turn on christy's teaching
head
what if someone said okay i want to
commit i know i need to do this but like
what are the first let's say
two things that they need to do to
actually commit
to the process to the journey so you
know one of the things we talk a lot
around here is action i tell people all
the time
it's not the thought that counts i don't
know who came up with that no one cares
what you thought about doing
no one's bragging about what your
husband thought about getting you for
your anniversary
no one's posting on facebook about what
your kids thought about earning on their
report cards
it's what you do that counts but what's
interesting is
if you take a tiny baby step literally a
baby step in anything not just financial
baby steps
but that's why we broke it down this way
if you take a tiny baby step
it builds your confidence and it fuels
your momentum
to take the second tiny baby step and
the 30 tiny baby step and so on you look
up one day
and you've built the business you've
lost the way you've gotten out of debt
you've done the thing
but it didn't happen overnight it
happened one tiny baby step at a time
but it all
started with taking a step it's that
step that moves it's the first domino
yes then the second is easier the third
is easier you start to get some
adrenaline some endorphins some reward
from your hard work some payoff you cut
off
cut up the credit card you lose the
weight you whatever that thing is you
get your first sale you're like oh my
gosh i'm doing this yes
research shows anthony that the most
motivating thing
to people male female any age does not
matter
the most motivating thing to human
beings from a psychological perspective
is not
money it's not rewards it's not uh
recognition
it's seeing progress seeing the scale to
go down seeing the bank account go up
you see progress you want to do more of
that so make some progress
i told you see a teacher y'all chrissy
wright ladies and gentlemen
yes yes yes oh man this has been a great
hour thank you chrissy thank you james
thank you kelly
uh hey you guys we'll be right back this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money my name
is anthony o'neill host of the popular
youtube and podcast show
the table with anthony o'neil and
co-hosting with me as number one
national bestselling author
and also host of the very popular the
christy wright
show that you can see on youtube and on
podcasts
and so we're here to take your phone
calls by anything if you're a lady want
to start a business give christy wright
a call if you're a lady you want to
figure out how to go after your dreams
and your purpose give christy a call
you want to learn i was about to say
something i was about to say something i
was about to say it again
if you want to get a bag no no no no no
if you want if you want to make some
money if you want to learn how to get
your money right
and for the the hip hop culture if you
want to learn how to secure
a bag give us a call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
uh triple eight eight two five five two
two five and you can hit chrissy or
myself up on social media
christy christy b wright um and anthony
at anthony o'neil
let's go out to uh phoenix christie and
talk to a barbara
good afternoon barbara how can christy
and i help
hi um i have an invention and i'm trying
to figure out the steps i need to
take to make that happen and protect
myself oh
what's your invention barbara are we
allowed to know or is it a secret well
you know i'm not gonna say exactly it's
a cleaner product i have a cleaning
service
okay so it's something that i've looked
at
doing because i've used different things
you know to
to do this and um so i have something i
think will work
better than what anybody else has cool
that's awesome
so when you say you have this i'm
guessing you already have
a prototype or a sample that you created
on your own
or you need to get that made well yes
and yes
um i have part of it and i need to
make a it will require a handle so i
need to i have an
idea in my head of how i want the handle
to be because of how i want the
product to work but i i don't know do i
go to an engineer do i go to a lawyer
first do i
what do i do because i don't want
somebody to be able to feel my idea you
know i know i'm going to have
to have a patent on it yeah yeah
yeah well i would say i would say this
when you are
kind of uh just in those first early
stages of exploring and research
research and development you're kind of
getting prototypes you're asking
questions you're refining your idea
i genuinely would not worry about
someone stealing it because you're so
under the radar you're not
posting this all over the world you're
not broadcasting it you're just
discreetly going to some different
vendors
uh seeing who you know whether it's a
company a manufacturing company that
makes a
prototype a mold uh you know plastic
molds you got to look into some of the
cost and what's the most efficient way
to do it
i would encourage you to find the
um simplest smallest way to start
because if when you're looking at molds
for example if it's a plastic
based uh handle that you know whatever
your design is that can get really
pricey
in terms of upfront costs and i don't
want you to do that until you prove the
concept and get some sales in
but what you can do is you can just
start to dig around a little bit i would
say that
look in your area in phoenix first
search
locally because there's something so
invaluable to going in person
to the manufacturing plant to shaking
hands with the people that are running
it to seeing what their options are how
they work behind the scenes behind the
curtain
versus dealing with an online vendor
you're gonna have a lot more options
online but
gosh you just could also make some
mistakes and lose some money
in translation even if you did pick
someone online i would i would go travel
to where they're located to see
where that where and how they want to
look for these companies that
manufacturers
handles yeah that's what you're looking
for the other thing i would i would
do some digging is and this is uh this
is a very
common best practice in business don't
feel like you're doing anything shady
you can ask other companies that are
doing something similar that are
manufacturing their own
similar products maybe it's not a
cleaning handle but it's a different
type of handle or maybe it's a different
type of product in a different industry
and just say hey how'd you do this who'd
you talk to do you know of anybody
just ask around and that is a perfectly
normal thing to do in business a lot of
people will be willing to share
resources contacts
company names hey i've got a guy over
here he may not be the guy but he's got
someone over here
whatever the thing is you're just going
to do some scrappy digging
research and i would say that even when
you find
an option to manufacture your handle
you want to get three different samples
from three different vendors you want to
get three different quotes compare
costs compare commitment um and that
type of thing before you make your
decision and then and
only then barbara once you have got it
locked in you're like i want to go with
this company
here's how many we're going to
manufacture here's how much it's going
to cost here's what all the logistics
of fulfillment is once you do that
then i would get serious before you
maybe sign with them then i would get
serious about a patent
and and you don't need a patent attorney
you can go to uspto.gov
that's united states patent and
trademark office.gov
and you can uh file for a patent
yourself it's a little it's a little bit
of you know maybe two thousand dollars
you can do it yourself you don't need to
pay all the thousands of dollars and
attorneys fees to do that for you so you
do that then but first let's figure out
your idea and concept and then you're
ready to do the paperwork side of it but
that's awesome i think that's
i think that's really cool and i think
you should do it i can't wait to hear
how it goes that's really cool
wow listen that's why i said give us a
call we got we got the
she's the one right tell her how to do
it tell her how to save some money
still pursue her dreams but here's
here's the first steps yeah
that's why you know it can be
intimidating when you have an idea
because you're like well i've got this
awesome idea how do i bring it
bring it into action those first steps
can be a little a little intimidating
but you can do it
absolutely absolutely uh max is in
philadelphia uh good afternoon man how
can uh christy and i help
hey thank you so much for taking my call
really appreciate it yeah go ahead real
quick we got about two minutes so
uh good to your question so um yeah i'm
on baby step two
um i am trying to figure out ways to
increase
my shovel to fill this mess that i've
made in um i just uh
so i got a 5k increase for a new
position at work within the last couple
weeks
and i just found out that i got a little
over five thousand dollar bonus for the
year
okay um i have a pretty unique ability
to play
piano and sing on the side okay and i'm
wondering whether it's acceptable to
sort of put
some money into that whether it's you
know i've been thinking about getting
this piano shell that sort of mimics a
grand piano
to throw that tip chart kind of right in
people's faces uh for
those kind of request songs or you know
i'm kind of feeling guilty about even
the idea of putting a pause in the baby
baby steps um i also have to get into
some sort of car to be able to get to
those gigs
which i don't have right now how much
debt do you have right now uh max
so i have 13 in about so it's an
old car loan uh that isn't around
anymore due to an accident so i should
be getting some settlement money at some
point
okay i i have no idea when though but uh
and then uh like 250 thousand dollars in
student loans yeah yeah
yeah i'll tell you real quick max you
don't need to put any money from your
bonus into your side gig if you're in a
different type of business like you're a
fitness coach and you don't have
equipment to do what you need to do i'd
say yeah
you don't need it for what you do you're
able to do what you do on the side
without taking any money just get a
bigger tip jar
from like walmart and just stick it in
their face on top of the piano the
things that
i'm hearing don't sound necessary they
sound nice but not necessary
so put that money on your on your debt
don't worry about you don't need that to
do what you do
yeah man i agree i totally agree with
chrissy
there's no need to spend any extra money
or anything you need to put all the
money
uh towards your debt because you need
financial freedom you don't need
anything extra for your business now i
do want you to consider keep that side
gig
so you can keep some money generating
people towards your debt
but don't spend any more money into that
all right
get out of debt keep the bag this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
monique is in san antonio texas with
a great question for christy monique how
can
christina help hi y'all it's an honor to
be on your show i've been listening to
dave and everyone for years
um i have a question for christy i have
read ken coleman's proximity principle
and i just started your book christy
business boutique
awesome and um i'm just at the beginning
and kind of it's i feel like god's been
slapping in my face i've prayed about it
i've lived the corporate life forever
and i know there's so much more out
there for me i have a chronic illness i
do live with multiple sclerosis i've had
it for about seven years or so
and i want to share with not just other
people with multiple sclerosis but
anybody with a chronic illness the
importance of health and fitness
and a positive attitude i think goes a
long way too because
i'm open about it but there's people
that don't know and when people find out
i have this they're like i would have
never guessed that monique and
how do you do it because i know somebody
that has it and they don't they just
kind of have such a bad attitude i don't
want to do anything so
i've i want to start a blog well i have
my website already i purchased that
i don't know and i want to go into
fitness training for people with
disabilities and i just i don't know if
this is something that could potentially
become a career
or even how to start i've seen all these
like on facebook and everywhere oh
pay x amount 100 and we'll teach you how
to blog and earn money
and i just don't know if this is
something solely because i've seen in
your book you've said it
all you need is social media and you can
start a whole new career i guess i'm
still kind of how do i go about doing
this and is this
a idea that maybe could go somewhere
um it's kind of what i'm reaching out to
you for christy
yeah absolutely well first let me ask
you a really basic question
do you like to write i do
and i love telling my story because i
want to help people because i feel like
there's so much that people don't know
about the illness and what's available
to them out there
from everything to assistance with drugs
and do you need these certain
medications or not
yeah i feel like there's so much i've
learned in my time and um
the power of a positive attitude and how
to help people
so that's where i'm at and i do love to
talk and write about it okay well here
the reason i asked is because you
definitely have a message
and you definitely have people you want
to help with it so that is clear where i
want to challenge you a little bit
is blogging isn't your only way to do
that here's what i hear
and i'm just and you're just on the
phone with me monique i hear such
expressiveness in your voice that i
would be willing to bet you'd be good on
camera
you would be good on a podcast you would
be good on a youtube channel now i'm not
saying you have to do that but the
reason i'm challenging you there is
making money through blogging is very
similar to
making money through podcasting or
youtubing
so you really get to pick what is your
medium to share your message and maybe
you do multiple ones i do multiple ones
but you want to start with one you want
to start with one and get good at it to
get your message out what's cool is
when you start to help people through
that medium then you're going to learn
what messages are resonating what
information people need and you can
always add branches on to
how you do that now here's the deal
making money through blogging
or youtube or podcasting or anything
like that
is a slow process if you don't have a
product
product or service to sell you're
selling advertising or sponsorships or
affiliate marketing you've got to have
eyeballs
ears clicks to be able to monetize it if
you're talking about just monetizing
the blog itself or the podcast itself a
better way to approach it
is i'm going to look at this as a
marketing channel for anthony and i
we don't make very much money for our
company or ourselves through our podcast
show
where the money comes in is the back end
when we talk about oh by the way i have
a devotional living true 40 days to get
back to you or i have a book business
boutique or anthony has a book debt-free
degree
when we talk about these additional
resources that people buy that's where
the revenue
stream is but the the podcast the show
the blog that's the it's more of a
marketing megaphone as an example so
you can approach it either way you can
do both you can have affiliates and
sponsorships and we have that as
well but that's not going to be the bulk
of your revenue unless you just have a
massive following which when you're
starting you don't so
right what i want to challenge you to do
as a starting point is
think about which sounds the most fun to
you being on camera
through youtube being on a podcast or
writing and you like i said you can
always add them in later but man
if people are saying to you monique i
never would have known
that you struggle with this then
visually they see something in you
that inspires them and i don't think
that comes through in a blog
i just want to challenge you there
you're going to be able to possibly
amaze people inspire people help people
more when they see
your presentation on camera or hear the
expressiveness in your voice on a
podcast and they go oh my gosh she
struggles with ms i would never would
have known
and and make that much more of an impact
so i just want to challenge you there
you there's no right or wrong you do
what's right for you
but then begin to think about what's the
revenue stream
um in addition to is it a course is it
coaching
is it um you know some other type of
consulting is there some other
uh backend revenue stream that's going
to make it more profitable
for you faster than just waiting on
eyeballs to come and monetizing those to
advertisers so i just want you to think
about that the revenue side
but also think of the medium but i
definitely think you should do it when
you start to dip your toe in
you'll start to learn more about what
you like and what works and you want to
do more of that great question
wow man that was an amazing question
this is fine this is this is i love it i
love it man let's keep the conversation
going
let's go out to cincinnati have a
conversation here with allison
good afternoon alison how can christy
and i help
hi are you there yes what's up okay
um so my husband and i are trying to
decide
we're in baby step 3b
um and saving for a house what our
monthly payment should be
because we make about eight thousand
dollars a month
okay so that would be the twenty-five
percent for two thousand however
we have a one-year-old and a
three-year-old in full-time daycare
and that's a pretty big cost it's about
20 a month
okay so should we subtract that from the
8 000
to come up with the monthly mortgage
payment
i mean i think for you at this present
time now do you have no debt right
correct okay and you have a fully funded
emergency fund correct
yeah all right i just want to make sure
that we're super clear on that um so i
think for me
the bear max not the bear max but the
max
you can go to is two thousand dollars
that's going to be 25
of your take-home pay and so if you want
to go down
lower than two thousand dollars by all
means do that
if you feel as if you will be a little
bit more it will it will be a little bit
more comfortable for you and your family
um but i firmly believe that two
thousand dollars is a great mortgage
right
uh but then at the same time how can we
maybe cut out on some other
some other expenses so that we can live
in a comfortable house
but if you wanna go down to fifteen
hundred dollars a month totally great
it goes back to what we were talking
about earlier anthony where it's like
there's a
there's a comfort level that you get to
have the discernment to decide what are
we comfortable with i'll tell you for
matt and i
as we have made more money over the last
10 years we have not upgraded
our home and lifestyle we will at some
point but we haven't and so we have more
margin
and that margin is peace of mind when my
son went in the hospital a few years ago
peace of mind there's no even with an
emergency peace of mind
and so i will say that allison if you're
even a little bit concerned about
you don't have to go up to the limit
that's a rule of thumb absolutely you
can buy a home that's a little bit less
than that still meets what you want in a
home
but you don't have to max it out just
because you quote unquote can because
it's the formula
again use your discernment and your
comfort level and if you know like hey
i'd feel better having a little bit more
margin and wiggle room with two young
kids which are highly unpredictable
then by all means feel free to do that i
think you need to do what's right for
you
absolutely i mean absolutely what does
your husband think alison
we we go back and forth every day yeah
yeah i definitely i i definitely don't i
definitely agree with chrissy just sit
down with your husband
and you all figure out what's
comfortable for you just don't go above
two thousand dollars
but if you're saying hey let's just
stick around 1250 a month hey that is
that is great i mean we we want you to
be comfortable
uh we don't want you living paycheck to
paycheck we want you to have freedom we
want you to have
peace um but then at the same time i'm
not just looking at my mortgage payment
too chrissy i'm looking at everything
though
you know where can i cut out on some
things where can i cut off on daycare a
little bit where can i find maybe
i want to say a cheaper daycare but like
a daycare that may be still good
but even is within my budget yeah and
the other thing that's so interesting
too about margin especially when you're
in this baby step and this is kind of
what you're working towards
if you're able to be in a home you like
and have that margin
then when things come up you cash flow
easier you're not having to save for 10
months for
an expense it comes quicker because man
you've got so much margin to put at it
it just it makes a big difference
it really does it really does well y'all
i'm excited because coming up next on
the next segment
we got two young people on the debt free
stage
that's right so you all definitely want
to come back after this tell your mama
tell your daddy
get the cats get the dogs cause we bout
to have a debt free screen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christy america i'm excited
because we have in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
two young people james and megan's
megan see i'm getting excited can't say
a name right
man i get excited you know uh when i see
two young people on the stage um
who are clearly debt free so give us the
information
how much debt did you pay off we paid
off 93
000 in about 25 months
93 000 in 25
months yes y'all was working and then
how much
was your combined household income
during that time where did you start
where did you finish
well for the first six months we're at
about forty three thousand dollars
what and you went up to yeah i'm trying
to do the math here
okay and we went up to about a hundred
thirty thousand dollars look at
you a hundred and thirty then that's
chris that's how you secure the bag
right here on the stage his bag went big
so what okay so what happened uh
from for you ought to go from 43 000 to
130 000
income yeah yeah so we got out of
college and had
student loan debt and all those things
and so we
um he was finishing up the police
academy and i was working and then
it took a little while to find a job so
when he finally found a job we were able
to keep living like we were
living on one income in order to make
sure that we were paying off our debt
smart yeah what what do you two do i'm a
police officer and megan's a teacher
amazing two amazing careers that's right
thank you
both serving our country that's right
yes yes all right so
i'm assuming that ninety three thousand
dollars in student loans
majority of them well it was about sixty
thousand dollars in student loans
okay i had the majority of that um all
right uh two
car notes and just a couple other
miscellaneous like three thousand
oh so yeah thousand dollars in credit
card debt you're just very normal that's
it
student loans two nice cars and some you
know some other small stuff okay cool
so um what happened you know what made
you all want to attack this 93 000
in student loans well i didn't think we
had a problem at all we're just living
day to day
um and i got an invite we got to invite
to
attend my high school football coach
and his wife uh for dinner we met them
for dinner
and they were just happy they were
excited they were like hey we got to
tell you about this thing
we paid we're paying off our debt like
we're getting out of it and
just to see their faces light up and for
them to tell us i was like megan we we
have to do something
but before that um right after we got
married
someone actually gave us dave ramsey's
total money makeover book
okay with a hundred dollars so we took
the hundred dollars and we kind of
tossed the book aside like
we don't need that everybody does every
wedding gift ever
so after dan and carolyn uh invited us
over for dinner
we went back scrambling looking for the
book but we couldn't find it
we don't know who gave it to us either
so yeah so shout out to whoever gave us
that book for
our wedding gift but we read the book
and like i just lit up i read the book
in
a couple hours actually i just sat down
and read the whole thing and
megan was on board and
yeah wait you read the whole book in a
couple hours like in one two hours
it was well it was like it was like six
hours oh yeah no
not a couple but like six hours yeah
still reading the book in six hours but
it takes me six weeks
it usually does too but that book i just
couldn't put down for some reason
i was determined i was definitely
determined yeah that is cool
that is awesome so i'm curious when you
decided to make this commitment what was
the first like
few weeks like when you realized like
okay we've decided
and now you gotta make some sacrifices
and actually take action on it that for
some people between idea to action is
hard talk about that kind of that stage
right there yeah
yeah we our budget was really jacked up
the first time
so everybody says yeah we never sat down
and budgeted anything we didn't know
where our money was going or what was
happening so
it was just a mess yeah after that after
we finally
kind of configured what we wanted to
budget for everything it got easier but
it took some hard conversations letting
go of certain things and just
um making sure that we were doing what
we needed to do to get where we wanted
to go
so what would you two say is the key to
getting out of debt what's that
one key uh to the millions of people
listening to your message right now
um it definitely takes commitment um
with anything
i never went through a process before
where
i mean i was that committed for that
long too
i mean two years it was seemed like a
long time
it was it was a long journey but looking
back at it it went by quick to us
um but definitely commitment in if i can
add a one
b it would be budgeting for sure
yeah budgeting was was great yeah
that's so good um i'm gonna put you on a
spot
what's your why like why did you all
really really want to become debt free
think about 10 years down the road like
why does this matter to you two
as a married couple young married couple
well i'll kind of talk about my why i
don't know
um i was going through the police
academy i wasn't making any income
and megan was taking care of the entire
family and we had a
two-month-old son at home wow so um he
he's definitely our why my why
of why we did things i mean i don't want
him to go through the process we had
with student
loans and other debt so because we took
the
sacrifice the short sacrifice to pay off
our debt he would never have to
experience that again
so just knowing that i mean that's
amazing for me that's awesome
megan yeah i think mine was really
motivated by micah he
we had to struggle through and make sure
that our
our loans are paid off but we don't want
him to have to go through that
um and just not have to worry about
money in general yeah
that's so good who are y'all's two
biggest cheerleaders uh we actually had
a couple
um her sister alyssa and her husband
alex they
went through financial peace university
with us they actually are debt free as
well
that's great um and dan and carolyn the
couple that introduce us to the dave
ramsey playing
so shout out to them shout out to him
so how does it feel i mean how let me
ask this question if you don't want to
answer it
i might totally understand but how old
are you two i'm 26 and megan will be 26
next week
you're about to get fired up i know that
face i know that face you get excited
you're 26 years old paid off 93 000
in two years in one month
i just got to ask how does it feel to be
on the
end of the millennial age you know and
you're debt-free you have a beautiful
son
like how does it feel it feels
amazing it really does i i didn't know
it was gonna feel this great until it
hit us
i mean i thought the entire plan was a
scam
i want to be honest with you then uh i
mean we just saw
we just started tackling in debt our
debt we're like we can do this we really
can
i mean it feels amazing and it feels
amazing to not have to work all the
overtime now
now so just take a break and i mean it
feels
it feels amazing it does your hard work
has paid off that's amazing
listen man oh man i'm this is the ramsey
show so i got to be i got to be careful
what i say because i'm just excited for
you too
you know when i see young people like
yourself focused determined
living with intentionality saying hey we
want to be debt-free so our son
can enjoy life grow up without debt and
then pass that on to
his kids and to their kids it started
with you all that's right
you two are the legacy beginners man i
just i just salute you man so clearly
you two are on your way to becoming
everyday millionaires so we have a copy
of uh
our good friend chris hogan's book
everyday millionaires for you
man this this is amazing is micah here
he is
let's get him out let's get micah on the
stage you guys
man james and megan paid off 93
000. in 25 months making 43
130 000 in a year
let's hear a debt free scream counted
down
[Music]
wow i mean chris i mean at 26
you're older than me right christy okay
we don't need to bring that up
uh we don't know okay he feels a little
pointed anybody
i'm just saying if i'm just saying at 26
were you thinking like that
no i was hitting i was realizing i had
to turn something around that was the
beginning of my journey not the end of
it
for sure that for sure that's awesome
and christie is older to me hey
this is the ramsay's
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
ramsey show
and sitting in today is christy wright
number one national bestselling author
and anthony o'neil
and uh i've written a book once or twice
but man we are here to take your phone
calls and to really have a great time
we love laughing uh we love um just
talking and helping and serving people
and so we're gonna keep it going on the
phone lines uh chrissy let's have a
conversation with alex out in tampa
florida
good afternoon alex how can christy and
i help
hey y'all how's it going here uh a long
time less than our first time caller
over here
all right how can we help
i got a question for you all uh we are a
first time home buyer
and uh the real estate market down here
in north florida is hot
and just like it everywhere everywhere
else in the us
and uh just wanted to get your opinion
on as a
first time home buyer here and um if we
should
still continue the rent or if we should
go ahead and pull the trigger
and uh buy or uh build right now
um or wait till the summer or wait till
you know
no one can come to the market but i was
just curious on what your
thoughts were on that and says this is
the highest the market's ever been
with uh with the lowest inventory cool
great great great give me a little bit
about yourself you know how much
are you out of debt uh yeah yeah we are
completely out of debt it's gonna be
uh my fiance uh courtney and i okay uh
we uh we have about 180 uh saved up
we're completely out of debt okay 108.
um is that 180k on top of your savings
or is that total 180 000.
uh that's a total of a 180 a thousand
dollars saved between the
two of us that's amazing that's real i
mean you you you two are killing the
game all right
so yeah um so i like that so do you two
plan on staying in florida once you two
get married
uh yeah so we're getting married here in
a few months and uh
we'll be uh we'll be the uh in the tampa
area
looking for a uh home cool great well
here's my suggestion
you clearly have the money okay um i'm
not going to put i'm not going to spend
180
000 to put down on a home i'm going to
look at what what will it take to have
at least three to six months of your
emergencies inside of there if you two
have a stable income a stable job
uh then i would definitely go ahead and
just keep it down to maybe uh just three
months
uh but if you're like in freelance uh
entrepreneurship type stuff i would go
ahead and set aside six months
and so you'll have at least 100 000 put
into a home so
generally what what what we tend to say
is
um wait one year after you get married
so you and your wife together can go
around looking and see what
you know what you all like get used to
living with each other and i still like
that
for you too even though you all are
already in tampa and you're going to
stay in tampa
but i do believe that you should go in
ahead and just maybe save up a little
bit more
and just spend at least give yourself
six months in the same house
learning each other learning what you
like learning okay
we need this now since we understand how
to
live with each other uh so i would
suggest right
uh when are y'all getting married alex
yeah we're getting married in
september oh congratulations well it's
interesting too because what's so cool
about your position um financially
especially
is you have options so if something
happened to come on the market that's
just the most perfect house in the whole
world and you prayed about it you feel
like god is this is the thing
then you're in a position to buy it if
you wanted to but i could not agree with
anthony moore because i will tell you
totally transparent and this is not
talking behind
matt's back but matt and i would both
agree the first marriage first year of
marriage was hard
everyone talks about the newlywed phase
and it is fun but you are bringing your
own set of expectations to even just
living in a house with someone of how
they grew up and you grew up and who's
doing what dishes and chores and
and so what's so cool is if you add the
extra stress of
buying a home decorating a home uh
owning a home and all the maintenance
that goes into that on top of
that first year it will add to your
stress now it's not that you can't do it
but i agree with anthony i think if you
babystep that and you said okay first
step
let's just get used to living together
as newlyweds with less pressure and the
landlord can take care of the
maintenance
second step let's buy a home and and
take on that new level of challenge
together i think it's just going to
spread it out make it a little bit more
enjoyable for you
it's not like you have to but man i
think that's the maybe the smarter
option yeah great question alex and
congrats on
yeah congratulations your wife doing
that hey stay on the line since you two
are getting married i'm gonna have kelly
give you
a free year subscription to um ramsay
plus
and so because you all are gonna be
starting off in baby steps four through
six
and so i definitely would love to uh
just sew into y'all's marriage because i
i'm praying that
it's going to be fruitful and you all
will be married for years and years and
years and years and years
until both of you all go home to see the
lord so that's alone forever
hey blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer for custom window covering
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsey to get the best deal
rules and restrictions apply today's
question comes from dylan
in new york um i've been a part of i've
been a part-time
freelance proof reader for a little over
two years now
i'm ready to expand my business but
there are only so many hours in a day
christy
i currently turn down about two projects
a month because i don't have
time to do them i'm thinking about
subcontracting out the projects
i don't have time for but i'm not sure
how i would structure their pay
or if it's morally okay to accept work
from a client
and then give it to someone else to do
though i would review
every job to make sure it's highly
quality high quality
what do you think christy two things
super simple number one raise your
prices
period raise your prices if the demand
is higher than the supply the
supply being the hours you have in a day
it is time to raise your prices
and then that is just that's showing you
what you're able to do at this time it's
a great time to raise your prices
second thing is when you talk about is
it morally okay to accept work from a
client and then give it to someone else
do
that is what business is when you employ
team members so
of course it's morally okay the only
thing that you might want to do just for
your own peace of mind and to be fully
up front with the client is to let them
know that your subcontractor your team
member however you want to
uh phrase it and structure that that
person's employment with you
uh you should be upfront that they're
going to do it and you let them know
like hey i'm going to pass this off to
so and so they're going to but i'm going
to supervise it i'm going to make sure
the quality of work
when it comes to that you need to think
through the pay so you're going to
build in to the the cost for the client
the amount that you're going to pay the
subcontractor the team member to do it
and the amount of money that you're
going to make off the top for running
the business because you're running a
business now and you're employing people
so you can do either
you can raise your prices or subcontract
it out
and manage that like a business or you
can do both
and uh all of them are good ideas and
that's exactly what you should be doing
when your business is expanding and the
demand is growing great question oh man
that's such a
real good question um you know it's so
funny because
when you was answering the question
christy i was like absolutely man people
do this every single
time all the time every single day yeah
that's right i call one company yeah
we're going to send out a contractor but
i called you
well they work for us that's right so
there's nothing wrong with it just make
sure that whoever is representing you
is doing a great job at what they're
doing so this is what's your brand on it
your name on it your reputation
absolutely hey you guys are you feeling
um stuck with your money
uh like you've never you'll never get
out of debt or save enough uh for the
future listen
it doesn't have to be that way you can
make progress with your money
and faster than you think but the only
way to make it happen
is with a budget again we just heard the
debt-free couple say
you gotta get on the b word a budget
that's why you need
ramsey plus membership you'll get access
to the premium version of our every
dollar budgeting app
you'll be able to plan out every dollar
you'll spend
and save before the month begins connect
your budget to your bank so you can
never
miss any transactions and get custom
budget reports
that shows you where you can find more
money
and put towards your goals when you
budget and get intentional
with your money you will make progress
let me say that one more time when you
budget when you have a vision for your
money
and get intentional with your money
you will make progress and progress very
fast
and you can start budgeting for free
today
to start your free trial of ramsey plus
go to daveramsey.com
that's daveramsey.com
i can't tell you how much i love
budgeting
i didn't like it at first chris it would
be real really oh i didn't like it
i didn't like it because i i was able to
see where i was spending the majority of
my money and i didn't like looking at
myself
see i like i'm the control freak i like
the control like oh i get to just move
these numbers around and control it and
see it
and it's like a game i love it i'm glad
that you loved it
i didn't like it but now i do love it
well that's a wrap for this hour man
it's been fun christy
james kelly america thank you so much
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money my name is anthony o'neil
host of the
popular youtube and podcast show the
table with anthony o'neil
and co-hosting with me today is number
one national best-selling author christy
wright and host
of the christy wright show and author of
the most recent book
um living true yeah i'm so excited about
that christy this book is fire
so this is so fun because did you know i
don't know if you knew this ao
okay this is the very first devotional
our company's ever put out
you know i just love to get away with
stuff and try i just i love to push the
boundaries a little bit i see you
listen a couple years ago i just really
felt a desire and a call to write a
devotional and
here's the thing this is something i
have felt and this is something i've
heard from for over a decade of working
with women i remember speaking at one of
my first speaking events at purdue
university in 2010
and a woman walked up to me after i
spoke on life balance and she said
i just feel like i've lost myself wow
and i've heard those words
and it's not just women but i think
women uniquely experience that whether
it's in motherhood different seasons of
life
different jobs or careers you feel like
you lose yourself in your own life and
you're going where
am i wow in my own life and so i really
felt like god was calling me to
tackle this topic so we released it just
a couple months ago it's called living
true
40 days to get back to you and what's
cool about 40 days
and you know this because you're a
church guy but 40 is a very biblical
number
and it's also not intimidating for a
busy
woman that wants to read it because even
even not just 365 days but 100 days
that's
that's a big commitment for someone
who's super busy but 40 days
to get back to you and i walk through
four sections who god is
who you are where you are in your season
of life and where you're going and what
god says about each of those we spend 10
days
on each of them and ao it's been really
cool and you know this when you put
something new out in the world
you're excited about it but it feels a
little bit vulnerable and you're like i
don't know is this going to connect is
this going to do what i want it to do
and it is just blowing up in terms of
reviews and and the the stories of
people spending time with god or god
speaking to them on just what they
needed here on just that day which by
the way
is what god does that's not what
christie wrote does that's what god does
and the holy spirit but it has been cool
to see how god is using that
to help women get back to themselves and
get back to who they were created to be
man listen listen you guys i need you to
get this book um and
for the brothers get the book for your
wife oh mother's day is coming up oh
mother's day is coming up you know get
the book for your mother get the book
for your wife get the book for your
girlfriends and you know i want you to
live
true you know what i was thinking about
doing so 40
40 such a biblical number with the uh 40
days it rained 40 days jesus was tempted
in the wilderness you know another 40
days
between the resurrection and the
ascension so i think i'm going to start
on monday
april 5th the day after easter and i
think i'm going to walk through this on
instagram
with people for those 40 days when jesus
appears i mean i know it's symbolic
because it's yesterday but wouldn't that
be cool
i think i'm gonna do that absolutely if
you follow me on instagram at
christybright we're gonna walk through
that so get your copy so you can join us
for those 40 days
go to chrissyright.com you guys go to
chrissyright.com
get get a book so that when she launches
this on her instagram
um you can follow her you can connect
with her on instagram at christybewright
again that's christy b wright uh so that
way you can be a part of this get the
book
get on there because i'm telling you
right now christy wright got energy so
you're not gonna be bored you're not
gonna fall asleep
or lazy or slowing down she's gonna come
with the energy and so and
you know what if it comes about living
true if you have any questions about
living true about balance life balance
uh give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five
we have another hour with you all today
four more segments or actually three
more segments after this
so we are here to answer your question
about uh
money i've been teaching uh the world
today about what the definition of
securing the bag so security
that's been a theme of today's show yeah
you know sorry about getting it getting
a check
making money and so if you have a
question about you know how to get more
money
how to get out of debt how to secure the
bag
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five uh daniel's with
us
in uh jackson mississippi uh daniel good
afternoon how can
uh chrissy and i help absolutely thank
y'all for letting me come on
and uh i'll try to make this pretty
brief
my question is i am currently working
through the steps
and i'm about a month away from
getting baby step three and moving into
four
okay um and so basically i have
a positive cash flow of about three
thousand dollars a month okay
and uh my current financial advisor
has gone more the route of uh
encouraging heavy investment in 401k and
raw
okay basically to the point where i'm
not paying extra on my mortgage and i
know
um the the advice i've gotten so far is
that
uh to do it the way that you do 15 and
then pay down your house
uh is some people say safe money or
incredibly conservative
um but can you help me understand a bit
better the benefits of going that 15
route and paying down the home early
yeah yeah so let me ask you this
question how much is your
your um financial advisor telling you to
invest
yeah so he's essentially uh 40
of my uh gross income so
uh he is out of that 3 000
he's encouraging me to invest 21.25 a
month
and how do you listen up
i'm sorry i say again i mean and how do
you live off of that
right yeah yeah no i agree and so here's
the thing i agree and
go ahead what we teach daniel is we want
you to live comfortable we want you to
live below your means
um how old are you if you don't mind me
asking 21.
okay 29 so you're a young guy okay
you're young like christy and i
and so we have no problem with you uh
i have no problem with you even being
aggressive with your investing but what
i want you to do is first go ahead and
attack the 15
and then go ahead and pay off your
mortgage while you're doing that now
once you pay off your mortgage
and you're completely debt free baby
step number seven
is build wealth and give so if you want
to go back and up your investments
you have that option you can do that if
you want to go out there and start
purchasing some land start purchasing
some real estate
you can do that but right now the main
thing is start
investing and at the 15
minimum and then get very aggressive
with paying off your mortgage
so that way you could be 100 debt free
going into maybe your late 30s and your
early 40s
and if you and if you're married at that
time your spouse decided hey
let's invest some more over here or
let's do this with real estate or let's
open up this business
by all means you have the right to do
that because you're in the
the step that requires you or will not
requires you but it's the step to build
wealth and give
but right now you're young i would
rather you focus on paying
off debt because i want financial
freedom um i want
bondage off of you and and so that's
what i would
really really focus on uh brother uh
because
yeah so i what i would suggest is to
interview another financial advisor i
would go to smartvestorpro.com go to
daveramsey.com
look up one of our smart investors don't
leave your financial advisor yet but
interview one of ours
uh you'll get about five phone calls
from five solid people who
i fully endorse christy fully endorsed
stay fully endorsed
and just have a conversation with them
and get get some other advice
because again i want you to grow doing
this process
i want you to build wealth during this
process but at the same time once you
get the right wisdom below in this
journey
and yeah and it's a marathon daniel it's
a marathon not a sprint you want to
enjoy your life along the way you want
to be conservative
but you want to enjoy your life not have
you know nothing to live on and enjoy it
just because you're
you're investing so much oh yeah man
yeah
40 it's a great question i mean it's
good that he's asking that's cool
gotta ask it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven
that even in adversity that you have
what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
taxes christy nobody wants to do them
but you know what we all have to do them
but with ramsey smart tax you finally
have an easy
money smart way to foul online the other
software out there
it's not what it's cracked up to be let
me just be 100 with you all right
they say it's free but no turbo tax is
not free for the vast majority of people
who use it
they sign up racket up the price and
suddenly
free turns into forty dollars sixty
dollars even up to a hundred and twenty
dollars which is ridiculous
but you know what here ramsay solutions
we love our people and we don't jack
you around like that the cost to file a
federal return with ramsey smart tax is
crystal clear
17 or 37 not 60 not 120
and depending on the level of support
you need plus 32 dollars
if you have to file state taxes and some
folks
don't just like tennessee but listen
it's not just about cost our technology
and support
we'll go toe-to-toe with turbo any day
of the week
and we will never let me say this again
we will never
leverage your financial situation to
sell you credit cards
and ridiculous loans like a lot of these
young people not young people like a lot
of these other companies do
sign up for smart tax uh for free and
take a
look around the software you won't pay
a thing till you are confident you've
got your taxes
right and you're ready to click file so
take out your phones right now actually
you should have your phones out right
now
if you're driving don't drive in text i
want you to text the word tax
tax 233789
that's tax tax 233789
let me tell you something people use tax
software
thinking these companies have their best
interest at heart
and they don't yeah and that's why they
are selling you all these credit cards
and all these ridiculous things and you
go to it and you think oh well they're
experts they're
financial experts they know taxes i can
trust them i should
get this credit card and man people are
making some mistakes
with their whole financial future
because of that they're leading them
astray that's why it's so important to
use
a company you trust that's why we want
to help you with this
yes yes i'm telling you right now um you
know
i actually fouled through my account but
i mean if i didn't have one i would
definitely be using this
yeah you know because i mean it's clear
i might have actually walked through it
myself
um even on my youtube shows show people
how to do it and this is super clear
and they ask you all the right questions
to make sure that you're filing
correctly
and you won't have any trouble uh
legally down the road that's so good and
so again i want to say this again i want
you to text the word tax
tax 233 789 and i promise you you'll
think ramsay solutions
uh later on we're going to go out to
arkansas and talk to rachel
rachel good afternoon how can christy
and i help
good afternoon how are you guys doing
well doing well thanks for calling in
how can we help
um so i have my
like three to six months of emergency
fund and i'm just wondering
um how much is good like percentage-wise
for a down payment on a house
yeah yeah yeah that's a good question so
what we teach here at ram solutions has
baby set 3b
once you get once you are out of debt
once you have a fully funded emergency
fund you move over to 3b and you save
10 to 20 percent to put down on a home
now rachel the ideal situation is going
to pay for a cash but
a lot of us are not going to pay for a
cash i know i couldn't pay for mine cash
unbe real right here in the ramsey show
and so
uh the bare minimum we say is 10 to 20
percent to put
down when are you looking to purchase a
home rachel
um in the near future um
my roommate situation is not like ideal
and i just also don't like the fact that
i just keep putting money into rent and
i'm not really getting anything
out of it besides short term yeah yeah
yeah don't don't
see and when i hear people say this like
oh man i'm wasting money on rent no
you're actually saving money
you know because uh in the long term i
get the philosophy behind
why you think like that but renting
allows you to set yourself up to make
the right decision
to purchase the home the right way so it
can be
it will save you a lot of money i know a
lot of people who will just do the
you know the fha loan 3.5 down get into
a house that they really can't afford
when they go to sell it they really
can't make any money off of it because
they didn't do it the right way
so what we teach here is to save 10 to
20
to put down on a home you're going to
finance at a 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage now some people say well
anthony that's a lot of money so here's
the thing when it comes to 20
rachel if you can put 20 down you have
20
equity inside of your home this is going
to help you avoid
a pmi private mortgage insurance all
right
and so if you are doing a private
mortgage insurance like what most
most fha loans do you're spending a lot
of money that doesn't go towards your
principal
or interest okay and we do not want you
to do that
but here's the bare minimum if you put
down 10
the key thing here is just make sure
that your mortgage payment
is less than 25 of your take-home pay
so put down that if it's 10 15 okay cool
great uh but the ideal situation would
be 20 so that way you can avoid pmi
sounds good i'm here oh man thank you so
much for calling in i really do
appreciate it
uh ryan is with us in fort wayne good
afternoon ryan how can christy and i
help
yeah so i kind of torn on
what to do as far as um housing
situation here so i'm on baby step two
and we're doing really really good
gazelle intensity feeling great
uh snapped all of our credit cards in
half uh canceled them all
yeah uh should have about half my
student loans paid off by the end of
this year
let's go awesome yes i'm feeling great
um
i was very very blessed income increased
last year and it's going to increase
this year as well too
so i got an email the other day saying
that
the guesstimation i guess is what i'm
kind of calling it that the equity on my
house has gone up just from being there
for a couple years and
the equity is getting really close to
how much my student loans
are on the outstanding balances right
now
would it make sense to sell the home in
the next couple years if the equity gets
past it and then rent
to kind of streamline baby step three or
just keep going with gazelle intensity
and build more equity and just be more
patient
that way when it comes to baby step
three you know i'll have more equity in
the house and
if we do sell the house we'll have that
much more for emergency funds investing
et cetera et cetera man such a great
question ryan and um
i love the tone of your voice i hear the
focus
um i hear it i hear the intentionality
inside of you
um the fact that you're willing to ask
this question about your home lets me
know
that that you and your family are very
serious about
paying off your debt so i want to
commend you and celebrate you for that
let's just say right now that you had no
debt you had a fully funded emergency
fund
would you want to sell the house yeah
you will so you you're not sold on this
house you don't love this house this is
not
love love we we do love the house the
thing is
we know the pro the family's probably
gonna expand in the future as well too
so we're gonna need more room okay um
but we got into this house
at a really really good price at a
really really good time in a really
strong housing market out here and it
worked
in our favor just don't know if i should
just keep riding this momentum train
that i'm on
or uh get into baby step 3 quicker if
that means getting out of debt sooner
and just renting
how much debt do you have real quick
close to about 50.
um 50 000 how much equity is in your
home
it's guesstimated between 38 040.
okay yeah um i'm going to stay in the
house right now
same same thank you good please i was
getting so nervous
yeah i'm staying in the house man i'm
going to stay in the house i'ma ride it
until
the house can no longer fit me and my
family fifty thousand dollars uh
real quickly what's your household
income combined between the wife and i
so we both work commission so
realistically we're going to be about
130. this year if this year goes well
we'll probably be close to about 160.
yeah
you could be debt free within the next
you know within the next
12 to 14 15 months if you all do this
and then here's the thing that's
interesting ryan sometimes when we get
so motivated we get so excited we're
like how can i fast track that and i get
it because i'm
wired the same way but what's
interesting is if you're not careful
you will get so excited you will make a
decision that just creates a different
set of problems for you
you then have to save up all over again
for a house you're renting you don't
like your landlord it's a headache
you're moving
and then you've got commissions and fees
and moves it's a different headache it's
not like you got rid of the problem you
just had a different problem so i would
say stay put
keep building equity just like ao said
get out of debt and then
do it patiently over time absolutely
that's right
y'all heard christie not so good no
chris no
you had it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
i just love that music that our producer
aka dj
is playing right there that's some good
music james thank you for that sir
i need you to bring you on to the table
with anthony o'neil
cause i like that music this is the
ramsay show triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five chrissy
wright and myself anthony o'neil
are here today to talk to you today
about your life your money
want to start a business uh whatever you
want to do uh give us a call we can
talk about relationships normally
chrissy when john deloney and i on
oh we get a lot of marriage and
relationship and boyfriend girlfriend
and should i move in questions
we haven't gotten any of those i thought
that's a i bet that's a fun
conversation between you and delivery oh
man listen
you know before the show my producer our
producer james came in and said hey man
you should be a little more softer when
you say things
you know i was like i understand i can
do that
if i try real real real hard and focus
he was like hey you shouldn't say that
because it could come off a certain kind
of way and i was like okay
all right cool great great great so you
know what we need to do next time we
need to set it up
and have people call in with faith
questions because i'm doing this devo
stuff right now you've got a church
background like we could just we could
just bring him to church ao i feel like
we could do that let's do it next time
we'll do that we got another segment
coming up after this if you have any
faith questions
um not really devo questions because
faith will even
to the devil but any faith questions
give us a call next segment
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let kelly know you got a faith
question
maybe she'll let you on maybe she won't
she's the boss
you know triple eight eight two five
five two two five andy is with us in
colorado springs
oh good afternoon andy i see you have a
question for christy talk to us what's
going on
hi guys it's a pleasure to to speak to
you today i
i recommend dave and his team everybody
and tell them i'd be a millionaire three
times over voted known he existed ten
years ago
you and everybody else right he did
really
i've got um i've got a weird issue that
cropped up today okay
i uh i own a coffee shop in colorado
springs
and i got an email we have we use a um
a an app for scheduling called home base
and we received an email today that they
are rolling out something really
exciting for my employees they're going
to be offering my employees
the ability to get cash advances on
their pay
at no cost to me and it's wonderful for
them
in case they need extra money yeah what
how many points do you have
i have 19. okay here's what i'm gonna do
andy and this is gonna sound drastic but
it's that important because i can hear
your voice this is
this is against your values period right
right yeah we're not going to use a
program that's against your values
period so here's what we're going to do
you're going to tell your 19 employees
which is absolutely something
you can manage on your own even if it is
just means you write checks to people
for their paychecks for a couple weeks
until you get a new program in place but
what i would do is i would go to the
leadership of that company and say i'm
canceling immediately
unless you take this off the table and
change this policy for my
employees if they will not back down
then you cancel and you let your team
know you send an email to your team and
say hey guys
i hate that this is happening we're
going to go with a new program uh we had
some differences
in leadership and values and we're just
not going to use a program you don't
even have to go in the details of what
it was
we're not going to use a program that's
uh against our values and we've done
that as a company just so you know andy
ramsey solutions has absolutely
pulled out i mean just slammed on the
emergency brake
with vendors uh companies that we've
used for different things the moment
they try to do something
that is not in line with our values
there's no price
that is worth it when you're running
your company you're running it because
you want it to be in line with your
value so what i would recommend you do
is first reach out to the leadership of
that scheduling app
try to get on a phone call and say
either this is not being offered and i
will consider staying with you for
for you know the time being or if they
will not you
immediately cancel your relationship
with them
i don't care if you use a google doc to
schedule your team members you got 19.
we're not talking about 500 people here
you can manage the schedule
uh just to me it is 500.
yeah i yeah i hear you but keep in mind
it's temporary right
it's going to be up maybe a month maybe
you make their schedule
by hand in an excel spreadsheet or
google doc for a month and that's it
and and or even it might even just be a
few days till you find something there's
a million options out there you just
need enough time
to be able to find something that's
better and that's gonna take you a few
days to do that so you're buying
yourself a little time
with your team and just tell your team
whatever their schedule is how long have
they been scheduled out through
like what do they know they're scheduled
through the schedule two weeks in
advance
okay okay you're fine they're set their
schedule set
their schedule set we're gonna pull out
of this company and figure out a
different option for you but i
absolutely would not let this roll out
to your team you will regret it it will
keep you up at night you will start to
hate yourself they are going to regret
it they are going to regret it so much
and there's no like consequences and
they tell you we don't sell your
information but you know
as soon as they start borrowing
something's gonna something's gonna drop
yeah this is gonna give everything in
you that is
like the red flag alarms going off is
absolutely accurate
and i want you to listen to that and i
want you to go ahead even though it may
feel uncomfortable to
do this it feels like a knee jerk
decision they're forcing you in this
position
and and you need to do what's best for
you your company and your team members
and the best thing is to not
allow this to roll out worried that i
was being more of a dad than a boss
no no no no here's what's interesting
here's what's interesting
this is not about you what you allow or
don't allow for your team members okay i
want to separate this for you really
quickly
what you're not going to allow is for
your company
to have operations that are
perpendicular to your values
yeah because your team members do not
separate you from the scheduling company
it's all you right it's all their
experience of their leadership
and so it's you endorsing this type of
action and you're not okay with that
this is not about you being a dad i mean
i don't mind giving like a i don't mind
giving anybody you know
an advance if they have a problem and i
figure out how they're going to pay back
so it doesn't hurt them and they can pay
their bills
but at least i have control over that
this this is going to be willy-nilly
it's like giving a cookie to a mouse
yeah no we're not we're not going to do
it andy you got you got you're on the
right track you know what you need to do
you just need to follow through with it
let communicate to your team members
come up with the new plan they know
their schedules for two weeks they're
fine two weeks is plenty of time for you
to get something else in place
uh but nothing is worth you having your
company run your
your business run in a way that's
perpendicular to your personal values
that's why you started your company
is so you could have a company in line
with your values and and you need to
stick with those
great question though i'm sorry that
happened man that stinks great question
sometimes yeah it does
uh blake is with us in texas good
afternoon blake uh real quick man you
have about a minute and a half
uh ask your question a question to
christy
hey how's it going guys um i me and my
fiance are on baby step two
uh and we started this about a week and
a half ago
uh we're down to just the vehicles and
the house but you know we're putting the
house back
and whatnot but
i'm looking to start
my painting company back up again i had
it a while back
a couple years ago i started it and then
i felt miserably
probably because the way i handled money
before i found dave ramsey and
listened to what he had to say and every
everyone in his
his studios had to say and started
taking that all in and
me and my fiance have been talking about
me starting it back out but i have a
full-time job i work 10 to 12 hours a
day
and i make about 60 000 a year where i'm
at um
and i need a i'm trying to figure out
where at what point i can actually
stop and then start something new like
that
um to make it your full-time job to make
it my full-time thing without harming my
family
uh being my fiance and my my 10 month
old child
and how to make that transition smoothly
as possible
totally i hear you here's the thing
you're going to build it up on the side
in every hour that you can nights
weekends get creative
take as many jobs as you can for a while
it's going to feel like you're working
two full-time jobs maybe even three
because you are
but you're gonna build up that income
enough that it can support you
financially that might mean getting
creative with your full-time job if
there's any way you can back off of some
of those
hours or whatever your days and
schedules look like from a logistics
standpoint
but the way we say it is you want to
pull the boat close enough to the dock
that when you step in the boat that side
business it's not falling in the water
so you need to build up that money
that's why i love doing a show with
christy wright hey this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today scripture and quote comes from
psalm 16
verse 11. you make known to me the path
of life
in your presence there is fullness of
joy at your right hand
are pleasures forevermore pharaoh
mcgalladen
says do not follow where the path may
lead
go instead where there is no path
and leave a trail i like that create
your own journey
and let people follow you well you know
what we're going to get back to the
phone calls and
i got to say man you know christy
today's been fun this is great
this has just really been fun i i like
doing the show with you
you know we gotta do this more we got a
lot of energy i love that about us i
love it
i love me some christy right we're gonna
go out to uh chicago illinois where it
is code right now have a conversation
with drivers drivers hey man is it cold
out there
uh it's not too bad it's kind of warming
up
what's the weather travis i mean drivers
what's the weather man what's the
temperature
i'm sorry what's the temperature
um honestly i don't know for chicago
i'm a couple minutes out from there okay
okay all right all right
cuz you know y'all 40 here and you said
that
that's not too bad not for chicago
weather what's going on how can we help
oh my gosh um so right now
i work 40 miles away
i have to carpool with my friend to get
there because currently i don't have a
vehicle
um i've got about 1500 saved up
but i was wondering if i should just buy
a hooky
or if i should finance a very very small
loan for a vehicle just so i can get
there safely and not have to worry about
breaking down
i kind of feel like i already know you
guys answers but i just want a
reassurance
well um i'm pretty sure you know the
answer uh but i definitely do want to
you know i i want to say this in america
listen to me
we have to get out of saying by a
hooptie
by a dave ramsey car and just start
saying let's buy a reliable
car that would get me from point a to
point b that may not be my dream car
i believe in there there's power in what
we say and if we say it's a hooptie it's
going to become a hoop d
and we're going to treat it like it's a
hooptie and so uh
drivers what i would definitely say is
yes avoid student loans i get it
oh man i'm scared if i buy this fifteen
hundred dollar car
this two thousand dollar car it's gonna
break down on me and you know what the
truth of the fact is
it might but so can a used car you know
any kind of used car i purchased a
beautiful high-end luxury car christy
uh about four months ago before i
totally doing this winter storm
and within not even a week of me having
a car
the car broke down i had to take it back
to the shop so i think
for for for yourself man i would
definitely go out there and look
i would see if i can just sacrifice
maybe another month or two to get that
up to about maybe two to three thousand
dollars
and then look into a good reliable car
honda you know a honda product a toyota
product
a nissan product uh by maybe like a 2
2000
maybe like a 2010 acura tl's are going
for right around
uh five thousand dollars if you get in
high mileage of about 150
and 150 on a honda product is is is
beautiful
it's just now getting started so what i
would just definitely do some research
man
um because i'm telling you right now you
can find you a reliable car
i saw a uh a honda accord with 200
000 miles on it uh chris and it was
going for 3 200
and a honda accord 2010 that is a good
car that is a reliable car
as long as you just keep the maintenance
up on it so drivers know stay away from
the debt
stay away from the debt do not finance
anything
right uh the only reason why i asked was
because like i said
um i do get a carpool with my friends
and it is about 40 miles there um
but he's going to be moving soon okay
and what i wouldn't have a ride there
anymore what soon
um well he doesn't really know honestly
but he's trying to get it within the
month
okay within a month all right cool so
then start looking start looking now you
have fifteen hundred dollars you can
find something
uh and just start looking you know but
no i'm not going to tell you anything
are there any public transportation
options from where you are
are you going into the city is there
anything like that
uh i believe so i think there's a train
but
i don't know uh the scheduling for it
yet because i work overnights
well the only reason i'm asking is
because here's what here's what i don't
like anthony i don't like
in anything in life when i feel like i
have two bad options
and and so a car loan bad option or no
car bad option
so what i would just encourage you to do
is just explore all your options get
super creative you still may not end up
going one of those routes but it's going
gonna make you feel more empowered
to go i've got five options and i'm
gonna choose the best option
of these five options versus i've only
got two i'm painting in a corner i don't
like being in that position i don't
think you do either
and so if you look into this and you
realize
okay the person i'm carpooling with it's
actually going to be two months so i've
got more time
and oh by the way whenever i looked into
the train schedule they do have a
training schedule i could hop on that
buys me another couple months well how
much could i save in four months well
maybe i could save an extra four grand
well now you're looking at a really
awesome
five thousand dollar car man look how
your opportunities have opened up just
because you explored outside the box
of your two bad options it seems like
right now so i would just i would write
it down look at all your options what
realistically are we talking about with
this carpool friend
what are the terrain options public
transportation options is there anyone
else in your area you could carpool
could you put something on your
neighborhood facebook
post go hey does anybody work in the
city i go this way would you ever want a
car pool
uh just get creative get a little
scrappy and that's gonna give you more
options to choose from and that's always
a good place to be
i love it thank you for doing it uh
saying that christy
uh let's oh man chris let me ask you
this question
in your and you're from your expertise
when people say they want to borrow
money to start a business
what do you tell them well i tell them
no
i know that comes as a huge shock to you
right now here's what i'll tell you that
i see when people ask this though
i see one of two things either one they
have been told or somewhere along the
way they believe
that they have to borrow money to start
business yeah and they believe that's
okay because they think what's not my
loan
it's the businesses loan so it's not
really mine i'm not taking on debt it's
the business's debt and they think
somehow this is separate from them
and i remind them that someone has to
pay those bills and that someone is you
yeah so it's still your debt and it's
all a bad idea so they have this belief
that the only way to start is to take
out
loans and take up business loans and
that's okay and i always encourage them
you can start small grow slow
dave ramsey started this company on a
card table in his living room you can
start small in cash flow
the second thing i see and this is this
is
very common as well but it's just a
different angle on it
there are some people that don't really
need to take out debt
but because they're starting this
business and it's like this vulnerable
time for them they're like i'm excited
i'm nervous i've got this idea
let's say it's a i use a fitness coach
example or someone that wants to do hair
it's a salon
i'm so excited but but i've got to go
spend all this money buy all this
equipment you know lease a space
all these things they have to do yeah
they have to do it ao they say they have
to do it yeah like they they can't be
business and i remind them that they
don't really have to do that they don't
have to buy those things and
more often than not they don't nine
times out of ten here's what they're
trying to do though
if you dig at their motivation they want
to buy something to make it real to them
they want to buy something to validate
it's kind of like when i graduated
college
and i needed some new
suits to go interview for jobs as if i
didn't have
any perfectly fine interview clothes i
needed
a new laptop bag i didn't need that ao i
had clothes that were perfectly fine to
interview in but i wanted to like
validate or justify i'm in the workforce
and do this
and i think a lot of people this
vulnerable stage of starting a business
they're trying to validate it and i just
remind them
buying stuff for your business doesn't
validate it money does
come on get money in your bank account
when you make a
sale your business is validated if
you're in your garage
working on a 1985 computer it's
validated when money's there and so i
just try to help people
bust the myths pull away the layers of
the lies they're believing to help them
understand what they really need to
start their business
which is tenacity and money not taking
out a loan or a bunch of equipment
you know what chrissy off subject but
you know what i needed
a new suit because my first job
interview was in a red
suit with a purple shirt i was fired
before i even
did the interview you actually don't
need something
merry christmas i want to thank christy
i want to thank our producer james child
and associate producer kelly daniel in
america remember the caliber of our
future
our financial future will be determined
by the decisions we made today
you made the right one by listening to
the ramsay show
[Music]
you